Well, it's been
a year since
Russian tanks
rolled across
Ukrainian borders,
triggering a war that killed
thousands of civilians,
forced millions to flee
and upended countless lives.
Tensions are high and extra
security measures are in place
in cities and towns
throughout Ukraine
as the country braces
for potential Russian attacks.
World leaders, meanwhile,
are expressing their solidarity
with Kiev.
The Polish prime minister
met with his counterpart
in the capital city to mark the occasion.
And the Ukrainian president
visited a hospital
there and awarded medals
to injured soldiers.
Earlier in an emotional address
to his troops.
A lot of Maslansky promised victory
in 2023
With us it is you
who will decide
whether we are all going to exist,
whether Ukraine is going to exist
every day. Every hour.
It is you.
Ukrainian soldiers which will decide it.
CNN's chief
international anchor Christiane
Amanpour joins me live in Kyiv.
Much nervousness as understand it
this morning
as to what might unfold in Ukraine.
But what's the mood like now, Christiane?
Well, Max, if you can imagine exactly.
Exactly.
A year ago
this time, this capital was under attack.
Surroundings were under attack.
Tank columns
were heading towards this capital
from the north.
Russia had landed
paratroopers at an airport nearby
this capital.
The idea was to take this capital
and decapitate the leadership.
But as you can see,
President Zelensky
and his army are still standing.
And he paid tribute
to those very soldiers
who have been maintaining
the resistance, defending and creating
counter offensives
over this past year
and also to the civilians
who have,
by and large,
all turned into overnight soldiers
all resisting this invasion by Russia,
which, yes,
it is its first full scale year,
but it's been going on
in the east since 2014.
So this country has been suffering
and suffering significant losses.
15,000 before this war started
this this current one.
And now who knows
tens of thousands of dead
and wounded in support of this country.
However they remain
by and large optimistic
that with the support of their allies
who you just saw in vigils
and moments of remembrance
in Europe and other capitals,
they remain optimistic here
that with that continued support
their resistance will continue as well.
Max,
we saw Western leaders speaking today
showing, you know, unity behind Ukraine,
also suggesting
that NATO's be stronger than it is
right now.
How would you rate the
state of the Western alliance
Well, again, and just to say
that as yet
today, there has been no full
frontal Russian attack on these cities.
So let's just keep our fingers crossed.
It's a very different situation
than it was exactly a year ago.
But over the last months,
you know that the Russians have been
using their missiles
and their offensives
against civilian targets,
including infrastructure.
All of that
to say
that the Ukrainians
have been expending
a huge amount of the weaponry
they've been receiving
and of the ammunition
they've been receiving.
And that needs to be stepped up.
According to all the NATO's leaders,
they need to get
much more ammunition here
for the weapons systems
that have already been delivered.
Very importantly and symbolically,
when you mentioned
and you showed the Polish
prime minister coming here,
he did come with the first of the Polish
leopard tanks, their German tanks,
but they've been released by Germany
from third party countries
to send them here.
And so symbolically,
the first has arrived.
But, of course, the question now
remains from President Zelensky,
who says that last year
our watchword was weapons.
This year it is speed, speed, speed.
We do not have time to waste
every single moment we waste
are more lives lost.
He's framed
this as a battle between David
and Goliath,
and David needs all the help
it can get
to have a knockout punch in his sling.
And so that is
what the message is for this second year
of war.
CNN's Christiane Amanpour
live for us in Kiev
on this one year anniversary.
Thank you so much.
The Ukrainian military
calling the anniversary a day
that has become
symbolic for the whole world.
And Kiev is preparing for
what could be another massive round
of Russian strikes.
To mark the occasion, as we were saying.
Meanwhile, a grinding war
of attrition continues, playing it out,
playing out along the eastern front lines
and Russian mercenaries
are now
claiming control of a village
near the embattled city of backwoods,
an area
where some of the fiercest fighting
has been taking place in his small car.
Joins me now
live and die Dnipro in eastern Ukraine.
What is the state of the front lines
right now? Alex
Max, as you say, it is grinding.
The fight in the east
and in the south is very active,
but those front lines
are relatively stagnant.
They haven't changed much since November.
When Ukrainians recaptured
the city of Harrison that had been held
by the Russians.
The fiercest fighting
recently has been in the past
few weeks and months
around that city of mood
where Ukrainian forces
have been facing up
against largely those mercenaries
and convicts from from the Volga Group.
There have been enormous losses
on both sides, incremental gains
by the Russian side, including today.
They claim
we can't verify it,
but they claim
that they have taken
a suburb of Back Mount
to the northwest of the city.
We spent yesterday in the dark
to the south
where Russians
have been trying to push forward.
That would be a key launching off point
for them to move deeper in into Donbas.
We know that the Russians
are trying to mount an offensive.
They have been
pushing forward in several areas,
including voiture
and back mud without much exists success.
Of course, Max,
the violence is not limited
to those front lines.
We have seen missile attacks,
drone attacks all across the country,
including here in the city.
Of De Dnipro over the past few weeks.
So the fighting does continue
very actively along those fronts.
The attacks
do continue in cities and towns
all across the country from the air.
And then, Max, in the coming weeks,
we are expecting the Ukrainians
to mount
their own counteroffensive,
to go on the attack
to try to claw back territory
from the Russians relatively soon Max.
Well, in the face
of growing international pressure
over its relationship with Moscow,
China
is making new calls
for a political settlement
to the Ukraine conflict
following a visit by Beijing's
top diplomat to the Kremlin.
China's foreign
ministry has said it's
willing to play a constructive role
in helping resolve issues, but provided
no details.
European leaders are urging
a sense of caution.
European Commission
President Ursula von der Leyen
who we heard from earlier, said
China's proposal needs to be looked
at in the context of its relationship
with Russia.
While Germany says
Beijing
should talk to both Moscow and Kiev.
Nic Robertson has been busy
trying to make sense of all of this.
Interesting here
what Fred was saying there about,
you know,
where Russia goes from here
in terms of resources.
I mean, there is talk about China
providing military resources to Russia.
We heard the head of NATO's
saying that there's intelligence
to suggest that might happen.
And the United States
has been saying the same thing.
It was interesting
that the Ukrainians said to China's
12 point
proposition, which isn't a peace plan,
but it's its 12 aspirations,
which was a positive response,
which was let's hear more about it.
I think Ukraine is in the business
of not turning down opportunities
for peace,
but they have to be on Ukraine's terms.
And there's nothing about that
in the language
that the Chinese have used so far.
And it's interesting what the US
Secretary of State,
Antony Blinken,
had to say today about the Chinese
proposal, which was,
you know, this is
okay, we
see this,
but it doesn't really have much on it.
He said, look,
China appears to be sort of
putting a public face of neutrality, but
actually they're not neutral in this,
their plight.
They're giving non-lethal assistance
to Russia.
They're an important outlet
for Russian goods,
specifically energy products.
And the biggest country
that's behind Russia at the moment.
And there's the possibility
that they may provide that lethal aid.
So I think what we're seeing around
the China
12 points is a healthy dose
of skepticism, but saying,
okay, if you've got something
let's move forward with it.
But it's got to be
achieving what both countries want.
And there's nothing in there
about Russia's illegal invasion.
There's no language around an invasion
which has offended
many people in the West.
It has. I mean, it's very clear.
China's position
here is a pro-Russian position
It's being talked about in
diplomatic terms today.
But that was very clear.
It was very clear
when Wang Yi, the chief
foreign policy adviser to President
Xi, spoke at the weekend.
He said, you know,
genuine
security issues must be addressed.
He was speaking about Russia's
security issues.
This is what Secretary of State
Antony Blinken says, that Russia
that China, rather,
is buying President Putin's
narrative about the reason for the war.
Hook, line and sinker.
He's not challenging it.
And of course
everyone else is
because they see it for what it is
not an accurate reflection
of what's happened.
Okay. Thank you, Nick.